[Music]
Giorgio's CEO is one of the biggest
social media stars on the planet this
powerhouse is a ball of entertainment
but Jojo has had a couple of moments in
her career that didn't exactly do her
any favors stay tuned to find out about
the biggest lie she spread and why many
people still can't forgive her for it
don't forget to hit that notification
belted never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more funds now let's check out
Jojo C waz cringe moments making fun of
Kendall let's start with a few Dance
Moms moments that definitely made some
people raise an eyebrow or two Jojo is
always known as the most outspoken one
and she definitely wasn't afraid to say
it like it is on Dance Moms well
sometimes it's best to say nothing at
all here's a little recap this moment
happened in season 6 episode 14 in later
seasons of Dance Moms it's obvious that
the girls go through many more emotions
which means a lot more drama for the
viewers in this particular episode
Kendall gets upset because she wanted to
do a Michael Jackson duet with Maddie it
was one of the last duets her and Maddie
were going to do together but because
Maddie is busy Kendall is pretty upset
as she has to practice with Jojo
understandable right if you and your BFF
have a chance to do one final duet
together you'd be upset too right well
Abby isn't having any of it and she
decides to give the NJ solo to Jojo
during the interview Jojo is explaining
what happened she rudely mocks Kendall's
voice and tells that Kendall is saying
she doesn't want to do a duet with Jojo
she wants Maddie she then adds that
she'd love to do the MJ dance because
she is MJ definitely not one of her
finest moments at all Jojo vs Kenzie
although Jojo doesn't generally have too
many shocking moments sometimes she just
makes you one of facepalm we're still
not over this moment so let's relive it
together season five was extremely
explosive the people are still able to
point to this moment as one of the
cringy Escoto moments ever if you're a
huge fan of the show you know that tap
dancing is extremely important to Abby
she always says that tap teaches you
about musicality and helps you become a
better dancer well Jojo doesn't think so
when the girls are stretching on the
floor before class Jojo asks the
girls what their favorite style of
dances McKenzie says it's tab
Jojo makes a smirking noise which throws
everyone off edan Mackenzie is like WTF
Jojo Kenzi then defends herself that
she's actually really advanced even
after Jojo pretty much asks why would
someone even choose tap as their fave
dance Kenzi fires back that she's
following in Maddie's footsteps as her
sister is known to be an amazing tapper
the facial expressions in the smirking
definitely labelled Jojo as rude in this
case and if you look at the moment
you'll see that the rest of the girls
were extremely surprised by JoJo's
comment
luckily Jojo still very sweet and she
later learned how to somewhat control
her thoughts unnecessary statements
before we move on to some non Dance Moms
moments let's check out one more comment
that made everyone cringe the more
competitive moms that come on the show
have a tendency to throw other kids
under the bus according to Abby it's
because the producers tell them being
competitive is how they'll secure their
spot on the show so naturally the og
moms aren't always fond of the new dance
moms or kids
this is JoJo's first episode so the
pressure is on the episode starts with
the usual pyramid and rehearsals for the
next competition Sara who is a part of
the select team gets to compete with the
elite team for the week a bunch of the
girls including Sarah and Jojo perform a
solo and as it turns out Sara scores
higher than Jojo but in a completely
different category things get a bit
heated
in the dressing room after when JoJo's
mom jessalyn points out that Abby wasn't
there to see Jojo solo but she came to
see Sarah's jessalyn tells Sarah that
Jojo had two points more than her which
is really unfair as they weren't even in
the same category Abby then asks Jojo
what she thinks of her mom saying stuff
like this to Sarah and Jojo replies that
if it's the truth
she doesn't mind it being said it was
definitely an unnecessary comment that
probably really hurt Sarah's feelings
the hair situation okay let's talk about
JoJo's hair plenty of people including
professional hairdressers have pointed
out that JoJo's hair routine isn't
exactly healthy it's been pointed out
before that putting bows in your head
the way Jojo does all the time really
hurts and damages your scalp
Jojo also revealed that she you
is a lot of hairspray and pretty much
wears a tight ponytail almost every day
many hair professionals have often
pointed out that wearing a tight
ponytail can come with plenty of
permanent hair damages that are hard to
cure this includes hair loss which is
something no one really wants
furthermore tight ponytails can also
result in a receding hairlines this
basically means your hair gets naturally
pushed back more and more and this
timeline photo clearly shows Joe Joe's
hairline problem and by the looks of it
it's not getting any better on top of
all of that Joe Joe admitted that her
hair isn't naturally blonde and her mom
colors it bleached blonde since she was
little combined with all of the above
it's safe to say Joe Joe's current hair
routine isn't exactly healthy for a
teenage girl well we're sure Joe Joe
will experiment with her style as she
grows older
we hope that her current hair routine
won't result in significant permanent
damage remember wearing tight ponytails
24/7 is really bad for you it's actually
I sleep with my hair just like this Joe
Joe's juice Joe Joe's juice is Joe Joe's
vlog every Dance Moms girl has her own
vlog channel but Joe Joe's has really
taken off resulting in millions of views
and plenty of sponsorships that's pretty
amazing for a teenage girl right we
totally see why she got the deal with
Nickelodeon but a lot of people just
can't help but cringe as they watched
some of Joe Joe's videos for some
inexplicable reason Joe Joe does this
thing she does at the end of every Joe
Joe juice video she actually pours
things on her head this could be
anything from slime to actual mixture of
really gross looking juice she isn't
afraid to pour things on herself just to
get that shock value out of viewers on
Joe Joe's juice Joe Joe also does a
variety of challenges and pretty much
shows her life to her audience if you've
never seen any of her videos let's just
say they're extremely fast paced and
there's a lot of pink it definitely
looks like a lot of fun but people have
also pointed out that they feel
secondhand embarrassment when they see
Joe Joe poor basically every liquid she
can find on her head sometimes she even
does this with friends but let's be
honest this girl really knows how to
make her life fun doesn't she Joe Joe's
vlog intro speaking of Joe Joe's vlog
have you ever seen
how many views this Chicot it's crazy
suitor energy people have equated her
personality with the likes of Jay Paul
we can totally see why but what's better
is Joe Joe's actual intros a lot of
vloggers tend to stick to the same intro
because it's just easier and catchy well
Joe Joe's intros are something else
this girl talks so fast for intros have
become a Twitter meme and pretty much
everyone has been trying to figure out
what she's actually saying people have
actually made videos trying to decode
what Joe Joe is saying in her intros and
to be completely honest
that's pretty hilarious Joe doe must be
aware of the popularity of her intros
because she's never really addressed
what she actually says instead she keeps
them guessing which means she's being
talked about even more it's a genius
marketing strategy isn't it her bubbly
personality is definitely reaching the
general public but we'll talk more about
that later can you decode Joe Joe's
intros take your best shot at trying to
understand what she says and leave it in
the comments below we promise this is an
unexpected challenge that will
definitely occupy you for a couple of
minutes Danielle for goli feud Joe Joe
has never had a major controversy apart
from the very last moment on this video
and this one although this one wasn't
even a controversy it may Twitter feel a
lot of secondhand embarrassment as
Minnie felt it was totally unnecessary
here's the summary in case you didn't
know Joe Joe is 15 so is Danielle Brooke
Ulis that cashed me outside girl
obviously these two are totally
different people despite the fact that
they're the same age and some people
can't help but point out that Joe Joe
actually seems like a better role model
for kids despite the fact that she's
still a bit childish at 15 well it's
fine for people to say whatever they
want things got a bit heated when Joe
Joe shared an opinion of one of her fans
the fans basically said that exact thing
and compared Joe Joe and Danielle saying
that Joe Joe is way better Joe Joe
replied with a thank you but many
pointed out that she's throwing
unnecessary shade at Danielle by
retweeting the same statement
Danielle then replied to joe joe with a
slightly ruder tweet and joe joe pointed
out that this is exactly what the fan
was talking about well it's good that
she defended her own personality was it
really necessary to criticize someone
else
who came from a completely different
background people have said Jojo should
not have gotten involved in that one
Twitter mean we've talked a lot about
Twitter in this video because well Jojo
has become quite a Twitter meme once the
general public found her videos and her
personality they started using it as a
way to joke about everything for example
when Twitter found out that Jojo is
actually ridiculously tall they couldn't
believe it
Jojo herself posted a tweet saying that
she's ready to become a meme and if you
know Twitter and it's harsh jokes you
know that wasn't her smartest idea she
got completely roasted with various
inappropriate jokes and many took it a
step too far but this is just one of the
many times Jojo found herself to be the
joke of the Twitter world speaking of
Twitter old school music fans
collectively lost it when someone posted
a photo of young girls who thought they
were going to a Jojo C wah concert their
moms weren't aware that Jojo see wha
isn't the only Jojo out there they ended
up at a concert of the old school Jojo
the one that's saying the famous leave
get out song and our songs are
definitely nothing like Jojo songs
absolutely hilarious even the old-school
Jojo laughed about that one but admitted
that the girls would have been in for a
rude awakening
if they actually attended her concert
when she lied about her dad one of the
most embarrassing and shocking moments
of JoJo's career actually comes from her
blog we all know that people do a lot of
things in their blog to get views and
let's be honest a lot of it is way too
controversial to be shown to people Jojo
had one of these moments and honestly
it's easily one of the most embarrassing
moments ever now deleted Jojo made a
video in which she told a long story
about her dad she said her dad was
seriously injured from a car accident
the story was actually pretty painful to
listen to and Jojo actually cried real
tears which was really upsetting people
of course thought it was real
why wouldn't they right well it turns
out that Jojo is actually a very
convincing actress because her dad
actually popped up at the end of the
video and he was totally fine she
admitted that she had nothing to film
for the day so she decided to make up a
story like a fanfiction well this would
have worked if she actually told people
from the beginning it was a made-up
story
but because she didn't say anything
people were extremely disappointed
especially because her acting was spot
on and it was very easy to believe that
this story was real it's without a doubt
one of Jo Jo's most controversial
moments but we're sure she learned from
every single one of those be positive be
happy and don't let the haters get their
way what do you think of Jo Jo Cielo
come let us know in the comments below
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]